[Music]
hey guys daniel rossen here for the
score esports tekken 7 is probably the
most exciting fighting game out there
right now it's got the sickest
storylines some of those incredible
players and of course it always brings
the hype so today we wanted to give you
a crash course in Tekken 7 we've put
together a list of what we consider to
be the top 10 greatest moments in Tekken
7 history so sit back relax and enjoy
some good ass TECA kicking off our list
at number 10 is a player who showed the
world what Tekken 7 is all about Japan
and Korea are one of Tekken's oldest
regional rivalries with both scenes
facing off again and again across the
series history and while Korea's often
considered the stronger region there are
many Japanese players who can make runs
when it counts Noby was already a dragon
off master from his time playing Tekken
6 and Tekken Tag 2 and when Tekken 7
came out he showed the world that Japan
was worth taking seriously in the new
game as well no be grinded his way
through Evo 2015 and defeated his
countrymen ow
in the grand finals I wanted to take it
to a final round let's see what he does
does he have enough oh my god did you
have a great phone incoming Rocky
full life and it's so pretty answer with
the running to know B is your evo 2015
tekken 7 champion and now goes home with
2nd place a few months later nobody beat
me at the king of the Iron Fist finals
to cement his place as the world
champion
honey my god this is so intense right
now back for good
while we have a champion and know me
2015 brand champion coming into the
number nine spot on our list is one of
the most improbable reverse sweeps in
Tekken 7 history and kagemaru pulled it
off in a grand finals match no less
the master cup nine Grand Finals looked
pretty cut and dry team aunty Benkei
were the underdogs facing off against
Nobby take' and you three of Japan's
best Tekken players their team yamasa
easily handled the first two members of
an T man cave but kagemaru and his Josie
brought it all back God he is putting
the team on his back
[Applause]
ladies and gentlemen we are going to the
final two
Josie
with Josie with Josie
our number eight spot goes to the NA
favorite who shocked the world by making
it out of the group of death at the
Tekken World Tour 2017 finals all eyes
were on one group heading into the
finals and because of how strong group 4
was many were quick to disregard fan
favorite Jimmy J Tran but against all
odds the American defeated some of the
game's best notably taking down the god
of Tekken knee in a heart-pounding game
of three to go two to one and make the
brackets
[Applause]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
France isn't considered a powerhouse
region when it comes to tacit which is
why super Akuma's incredible win at the
mix up 2019
takes the number seven spot on our list
it's hard to describe just how stacked
the event was but defying all odds the
hometown hero made his way through the
bracket Akuma felt a cherry berry mango
in winners before finding his second win
to roll over low high and losers just
that's not what you gonna do yeah how's
it going once again to get the top here
we go
gets the party started Hey oh he catches
the deduction there we go
one mix-up away one mix-up that's right
that's gonna be it
supa dupa eliminates you want you though
I have secured himself a spot and grand
finals and in the grand finals super
Akuma showed exactly why his Akuma is so
super demolishing the defending champion
in a stunning fashion yes coming in at
the number 6 spot is one of America's
finest Tekken moments Evo 2018 was an
incredible tournament for Tekken 7 and
will margins run was a big part of what
made it so special
always the faithful king player Majin
had never had tremendous success on
fighting games biggest stage but 2018
was different blasting his way through
the likes of John ding and neuroma to
make top 8 the king faithful found
himself against the challenge most
believed was too much for him to
overcome Tekken genius and defending Evo
champion Jay DC are no but either way
you know he you'd be a fool to bet
against him no matter what the situation
yeah matter what probably one of the
most consistent consistent second player
yes also a former Evo champion as well
the heart pounding series went back and
forth and when the dust settled lil
Majin completed one of the greatest
upsets in the game's history Oh
downstairs we should be able to get the
follow but the Tartars groan oh he went
for the heart all over I go he's gonna
do it he got
and market finally of us
I can feel it in my loin oh my god
three I'll take this right back up jump
on reverse sweet
this isn't gonna work we're going to
need to get a stunt double in here JDC
are you gets it one more he could do it
oh my gosh
[Applause]
I can't believe what I'm seeing any
chance I know we wanted an attorney let
the number 5 spot on our list treat you
to one of the greatest Tekken 7 sets of
all time JDC our vs. knee at the 2017
Rev major knee versus JD CR is one of
Tekken's greatest rivalries one that at
times gets a little personal factor
right now Jason needs to make something
happen now 10 seconds the sweeps gonna
do it me / JD CR did they shake it
called it Wow few players could
challenge a TCR in 2017 and the only one
that could was the god of Tekken himself
at a Rev major 2017 all bets were off no
one else mattered it was need versus JD
CR they met in the winners finals in a
match that is often considered one of
the best in the game's history
first game goes to me in a hand in
congratulatory fashion my email
it's gonna do there's no time flat
[Applause]
I'm speechless dude he is definitely
looking for used to make impo stuff to
try to get out away
JDC our man and while nee would lose to
JB CR again in the grand finals
it didn't matter they recognize each
other's greatness and buried the hatchet
with class 2017 make some noise a
gentleman it's like old France meeting
again there are few who can match the
raw dominance that nee shows in Tekken
which is why he's incredible run at
combo breaker 2019 takes the number 4
spot on our list the first nerds of 2019
marked an uncharacteristic low point for
nee after 2018 filled with titles he
couldn't seem to earn a win but nee
persevered and at combo breaker 2019 he
reminded us all why he's the best Tekken
player of all time after a loss to wrong
qu in winners and he clawed his way back
from losers round 3 and earned a rematch
with the man who put him there watch
sonic this combo
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
final then he moved on to Anakin and the
rest is taken history face one hookups
wage again for both legs I don't wanna
shoot me right now he's up to 2-0 in the
grand finals here you have to be in a
while here
going out and meeting around back to
zero Wow and now all go away look at
damage
[Applause]
[Applause]
fine fine
[Applause]
Breger cambiar no guys yo guys not gonna
tell me that one good though not will
tell me that one good though
it's okay it's alright and our number
three spot is the story of an unlikely
player their unlikely character and
their unlikely run to one of Tekken's of
biggest titles wrong shoe was nowhere
near the favorite at the 2018 Tekken
World Tour Finals he made it out of
groups but quickly stumbled in bracket
losing 202 knee but hell hath no fury
like a panda scorned and wrong shoe took
no prisoners in the loser's bracket
eventually facing off against ku Dons in
the grand finals and well we all know
how the rest plays out
[Music]
[Music]
Panda
father
[Applause]
[Laughter]
taking our runner-up spot is the story
of a king who made an epic return to his
throne in Tekken KU Don's is a legend
from the past a master who left the
scene and for years
chose not to return however after his
father's death ku Don found himself
playing Tekken again and while he didn't
find immediate success everyone knew
what he was capable of
could I sing ah you can Lord wider talk
about him is Oh boom man at the 2017
World Tour Finals kudos immediately put
everyone on notice powering his way
through to top eight and once he got
there he played some of the best Tekken
of his life against some of the best
Tekken players of the new guard Tekken's
new generation could not stop the king
from claiming what was rightfully his
and after an incredible final against
st. Jude Ahn's walked away with the
world title oh there's no time
it's crazy my god his hey the last time
qu dogs was in America was over ten
years ago for electric console six so
it's been over ten years have you seen
him here and he is still rocking double
gin things all the rage oh that's what
does so much damage huge so huge in the
torso touch celebration and
everyone's budging torso and last but
not least back from the grave everybody
I want you to step up man
make some noise so y'all check the World
Tour Finals champion
[Applause]
topping our list is our salon ashes
incredible 2019 a year that saw him
become the first-ever unified Evo
champion he started the year with an
unlikely out of nowhere win at Evo Japan
they put Pakistan on the Tekken map but
to silence any doubters that may have
thought he was a fluke Arslan went on to
win tournament after tournament and at
Evo in August parceling did it again
officially taking the title of the best
player in the world just a year ago no
one knew his name and now he leaves us
speechless this is the boat we have
probably all been waiting for we have
the shining star of Pakistan mr. arson
ash
[Music]
Wow what
hard money
Wow Wow and just like that our slant ash
I mean this is crazy and that's our list
do you think we missed some incredible
play well please resist the urge to
throw me off a volcano and instead let
us know in the comments below don't
forget to like the video subscribe to
the channel and we'll see you next time
thanks for watching if you want more
content like this hit the sub button and
bring that notification bell for unique
bite-sized videos you will find anywhere
else hit up our Instagram Twitter and
Facebook pages